[Music]
after almost a year
children in libya are returning to their
classroom administrators at this primary
school in tripoli
say they are taking safety measures
seriously
this school year is very different to
other years because of coronavirus
but thanks to god the measures we have
put in place are working very well
but some parents say the ministry of
education has been slow to provide
adequate protection abdel minam has four
children
but one is at a different school and he
can't start yet
the ministry of education should have
been more prepared the school one of my
other kids goes to has no running water
and a delay reopening the virus spreads
very quickly
so i am worried and fearful our children
can bring kovet back home from school
while this school has been given the ok
to open its doors
others have not yes
some schools are closed we have
allocated a budget for every school
in order for them to purchase the
necessary protection and fix their
issues
they should receive the fund soon but
some parents
are more optimistic
as parents we're very happy our kids are
back at school they went
a long time without studying my son has
down syndrome so school is very
important for his mind to develop
and for him to socialize with friends
these children are happy they are back
in school with their friends
this school has approximately 600
students
separated into two groups studying three
days a week
school officials here tell us that's to
allow for social distancing
inside classrooms although parents have
mixed feelings about the government's
preparation for the school year
for most of these children there's
nothing better than being back at their
desk
[Applause]
malatrina al jazeera triple h